[Applauso]
chiudete gli occhi
ora siete voi soli in un'isola deserta
senza acqua senza cibo
se volete andare a prendere un caffè con
un amico non potete avete solo tre cose
un pezzo di carta una matita è una
bottiglia
cosa fareste
io scrivere il messaggio di aiuto lo
inserirei nella bottiglia e lo getterà
in mare nella speranza che qualcuno
possa riceverlo è possa aiutarmi tra le
prime forme di comunicazione c'era
proprio questa una comunicazione molto
più lenta molto più lunga
se ci pensate in tempi più recenti
quando si andava in vacanza si spedivano
le famose cartoline con le foto patinate
dei luoghi visitati
con su delle affermazioni del tipo ti
voglio bene torno presto
dobbiamo vederci presto voglio che vieni
in vacanza con me però queste cartoline
e venivano spedite per posta quindi
arrivavano giorni anche settimane dopo
il ritorno dal viaggio
molto strano molto strano se si paragona
al messaggio whatsapp o la storia
distram di oggi
paragoniamo il messaggio whatsapp al
vostro amico in america una tradizionale
lettera al vostro amico in america le
differenze
nel primo caso possiamo facilmente
intuire se il messaggio è stato ricevuto
se è stato eletto sia deciso di
risponderci se online o meno nel secondo
caso
niente
chissà si è deciso di rispondermi chissà
se la ricevuto si aspettavano giorni
mesi
settimane infinite nella speranza di una
risposta
nonostante questo tormento di attesa
l'unico modo per mantenere legami
affettivi o dichiarare i propri pensieri
e le proprie emozioni
era questo scrivere tradizionale lettere
sedersi e scrivere
è proprio questa attesa questa frenesia
che ha portato a una necessità di una
comunicazione molto più veloce si
necessità perché necessità e il giusto
termine per descrivere la comunicazione
se ci pensiamo quando eravamo piccoli
l'unico modo per comunicare senza sapere
alcun parola forse le uniche parole che
sapevamo dire erano mamma e papà
facevamo versi striduli urla gesti
pronunciava mo parole incomprensibili
pur di far intendere quel che volevamo
ed è così che ci siamo abituati al mondo
d'oggi ai social le chiamate
internet ci siamo abituati a una
frenesia forse a una velocità da cui
ormai non possiamo più scappare per la
quale spesso siamo di cattivo umore
oppure ci perdiamo nei nostri pensieri
per qualche secondo
la comunicazione odierna la
comunicazione di arnad è un'arma a
doppio taglio
tutti noi abbiamo quasi un legame con la
tecnologia fin da piccoli siamo
cresciuti come se fosse una parte
essenziale della nostra vita
diciamo che smettiamo da sempre su
social ai di internet
forse però non è una cosa molto positiva
quanti di voi ad oggi sentono di
possedere un lessico di utilizzarlo nel
miglior dei modi
quasi nessuno io stessa non lo uso nella
sua varietà oramai finiamo tutto per
scrivere ha brigato lo stiamo
velocemente oppure abbiamo addirittura
creato un nostro linguaggio per esempio
siamo lol kringe
addirittura molti di noi usano delle
semplici emoji per descrivere veri e
propri stati d'animo
quanti di voi sarebbero in grado di
descrivere le proprie emozioni i propri
pensieri senza l'uso di s
quasi nessuno tutti noi preferiamo la
strada più semplice
nell'usarle ammettiamolo però è proprio
questo il problema perché poi non
riusciamo a esprimere ad identificare al
meglio tutto ciò se ormai ridotti a
rispondere a uno come stai con un tutto
bene indipendentemente da come si sta in
quel momento e forse proprio per la
paura di non essere compresi o di non
riuscire a esprimere realmente come si
ci sente
e proprio questa una delle paure più
grandi dell'uomo con la di non essere
capiti quella di non riuscire a
esprimersi la necessità di esprimersi il
bisogno di essere capiti dagli altri
esistono le comunicazioni verbali ma non
solo perché come esistono le parole
esiste nei gesti come esiste l'arte
esiste nei movimenti ci sono infinite
vie per arrivare al cuore e all'anima di
una persona
in un modo o nell'altro si cerca la
propria via per arrivare al cuore e
all'anima di una persona io non sono mai
stata brava con le parole non sono mai
stata brava a comunicare con gli altri
figuriamoci poi esprimere i miei
sentimenti apertamente e io come tanti
altri ho trovato la mia scappatoia nella
danza tutto ciò che non riesco ad
esprimere a parole lo esprimo col mio
corpo veri e propri pensieri emozioni
escono attraverso quello e non i miei
discorsi
forse è proprio l'essere consapevole del
proprio corpo del proprio movimento
provare delle emozioni e farle provera
di altri la cosa giusta la soluzione
è qualcosa di molto intimo molto
condiviso però a volte c'è la necessità
di essere bravi con le parole di
riuscire a esprimersi in un modo molto
semplice e diretto per esempio
puntiamo molto diretto spontaneo senza
paure un ti voglio bene
forse però abbiamo proprio paura di
queste parole di una parola detta male
di una verità che può ferire però allo
stesso tempo non vogliamo dire neanche
una bugia niente di questo è scontato
soprattutto
nelle generazioni di oggi dove una
semplice storia suisse ram può creare
fraintendimento litigi discussioni
quanti rapporti si sono distrutti dopo
una
è proprio la paura del fraintendimento
alla base delle nostre conversazioni
tanto che spesso quando diciamo una
battuta ad una persona che conosciamo da
poco non sappiamo abbiamo molta
confidenza
mettiamo subito le mani avanti dicendo
sto scherzando oppure era aironi ero
ironica
proprio questo il problema che dicevo
prima la paura di affrontare una persona
negli occhi nascondersi dietro un
messaggio dietro una chiamata
indipendentemente da quale sia il
discorso forse proprio questa moderna
messaggistica istantanea che ha rovinato
il nostro modo di comunicare lo ha
velocizzato ha installato nelle nostre
menti il concetto di essere semplici e
concisi
e se dovessimo tornare indietro se i
cellulari scomparissero internet non
esistesse più l'unica cosa da fare è
sedersi prenderete fogli e scrivere
delle lettere pur di mantenere dei
legami affettivi con le persone come
inizieremo a questa lettera
sarebbe qualcosa di forzato come un tema
di italiano oppure riusciremo davvero a
definire le nostre emozioni con il cuore
[Applauso]